那人是这样子的啊，
如果我没有得到过爱，
我渴望爱，
但当有一天我自己强大到我足以去给别人爱的时候，
他同时也会治愈。
我自己从小是在那个亲生父母送养的，
在这个收养的养父养母家待到17岁，
17岁开始以后就独立生活到现在，
28岁小的时候在养父养母家就是被打即骂的那种，
所以我继械的时候我就离家出走了。
这11年的过程当中，
自己成家了吗？
没有，
这11年的过程当中，
养父母有问你要过钱吗？
有，
差不多给了有十来万，
有十来万哈，
那相当不错啊，
我弟呢，
有正取名力以后就是陆续抵过十来万，
当时我的想法还是想修复这个状态呢，
就是我自己内心可能也是希望有父母和家人的这种陪伴的，
结果再告终，
然后是果断的斩断了与原生家庭的连接吧，
但是其实内心是好像是心结一样，
一直在困扰着我，
困扰你的点是什么呢？
第一个就是觉得这11年来都是自己独立一个人，
然后没有父母也没有家人的陪伴，
第二个的话就是我不知道要如何面对他们，
内心很拧巴的那种，
就是想跟他们完全放开这种连接，
然更想要有父母和家人的存在的。
我也不太清楚我现在的内心状态是什么，
但是我提起或者想起来这个事情的时候，
总是会非常影响自己的心理健康。
对于亲人这个概念，
我一直在跟大家在沟通，
或者说在谈我自己对亲人的这个概念，
我从来不觉得有血缘的就是亲人，
我也不觉得说他把我喂饭养大了，
他就一定是亲人，
亲人一定是你能感受到他在情感上确实是对你有关怀，
对你有牵挂，
盼着你过得好，
就是有很多没有血缘关系，
但是在你从小长大的过程当中，
是否出现过这些角色，
比如说老师，
比如说同学的妈妈，
邻居的姐姐，
或者工作了之后的工作的师傅、
前辈，
这些人，
人当中有没有他本性就是很善良，
就是看到你的时候会心疼你的遭遇，
会希望说啊，
这个女孩儿，
希望她能够越过越好，
如果需要我的帮衬的话，
在我的能力范围内，
我愿意帮衬帮衬他。
我相信在你长大的过程当中，
一定遇到过这些善良的人，
这些人在你生命中出现，
可能就是你上辈子的亲人，
可能就是你另一个维度，
或者说另一个平行世界里面真正的亲人。
在我的世界观里面，
我觉得我这一辈子需要去做的事情就是去身边，
去识别这些良师益友去。
去寻找我自己的亲人，
而至于说你和你养父母的关系的话，
要从良心上来讲，
你们养活了我，
给了我饭吃，
给了我一穿，
那么我要做的是能对得起我自己良心上那个度，
我在经济上对你们进行了回馈，
我也养活了你们，
我也给了你们饭吃，
给了你们遗传，
那只要满足我内心的那个平衡的点就够了。
至于说我能不能修复，
我能不能改变，
我能不能让他们从此以后就成为了我真正的亲人，
或者怎么怎么样了，
我跟你说，
别说你做不到，
他就算是那种哲学大师，
就算是那种世界级的心理学专家，
他都做不到。
所以你甭想这事儿，
这我能不能改善一下这个关系，
跟他们一起去共同去成长，
完了他们以后，
就能认识到他们曾经对我造成的伤害，
他们就能改，
从此以后我们就能其乐融融的生活在一起，
这只有在咱们中国的电视剧里面才出现，
保是强行大团圆，
在现实生活中的话，
就是用他们对待我的方式去对待他们，
我对得住我的良心。
结束了我可能是之前的想法，
就是希望能被父母爱吧，
这个人未必是你的养父母，
也有可能是你工作上的一个前辈，
也有可能是一个师姐，
也有可能是一个在你的师傅，
都有可能。
我们只是渴望被爱，
这个被爱未必。
要出自你的养父母，
是的，
就是在我17岁的那一年，
养父母家的哥哥和姐姐对我一直还不错啊，
那就跟他们搞好关系。
但是不幸的是，
在我17岁那一年，
就是养父母家的哥哥发现意外去世，
如果是这种情况的话，
我就看哥哥有没有留下来孩子，
如果哥哥留下来孩子的话，
那我就去扮演那个在精神上可以给这个孩子带来温暖的像，
就像亲人一样的这样一个关系。
你知道人是这样子的啊，
如果我没有得到过爱，
我渴望爱，
但当有一天我自己强大到我足以去给别人爱的时候，
他同时也会治愈我自己。
但是我现在发现一个很重要的问题，
就是我好像没有爱别人的能力。
不，
这是借口，
只要你内心是善良的，
如果你是有感恩之心的，
如果你的哥哥曾经对你好，
他有没有遗留下来什么需要关照的，
如果有孩子的话，
那我就像哥哥对我好的，
用哥哥对我好的方式去对待他的孩子，
你不要找借口，
不要说什么没有爱别人的能力，
你一定有，
是个人就该有哥哥家的小孩就是我想对他们好，
但是这个养父母就是不让我跟他们联系，
他是活的啊，
小孩是活的，
有地址的，
有学校的，
不行的话，
我是不是给孩子买个衣服，
鞋子、
袜子，
能不能接到老师啊？
我想对一个人好，
这个世界上所有的人都会为我让路，
可以穿越山海，
我想对一个好，
你可以克服重重困难。
我想说的是，
这11年来，
养父就是自己主动提出来说不要和我联系，
就是他没有我这个女儿，
他也不认我，
叫我以后也不要回到这个家里去。
我不是说是找借口，
就是对这个哥哥家的小孩不好，
或者主去做这些事情，
就是每当我想去做这些事情的时候，
这样就会跳出来各种那种做，
导致我可能就是建立出来内心的那种动念，
或者是信念崩，
他的每一次都是这样，
是这样，
姑娘，
当你的心理还在渴求养父母的爱的时候，
你对他们的动作行为就会有反应，
当你的心里有一天我不再渴养父母对我的认同，
对我的爱的时候，
他们怎么作，
在我看来就跟猴子耍戏是一样的，
就是你看到一个猴子在那里愤怒，
看到猴子在哪里耍，
你会有情绪的波动吗？
你不会记住了吗？
如果有一天你心里不再期待养父母对你有爱，
对你有认可的时候，
他们的所有的动作在你看来都会变成猴子耍戏法，
就不会再影响到你的情绪。
这件事实就是他们不爱我的这个事实就是我已经任清，
你早已经接受了，
我想去做这个事情的时候，
就他们会跳出来就。
骂的那种，
就是骂的非常难听的那种，
该拉黑就拉黑，
该远离就远离，
别的还有啥问题，
没有什么问题，
你要相信你自己，
你一定有爱别人的能力，
当你滋生出爱别人的能力的时候，
就是你幸福的时候，
我们是可以通过爱别人而得到幸福的。
我觉得自己自身的能量一直很低，
觉得没有办法，
多看龙菲姐的作品，
多看龙菲姐直播，
你之前一起加油啊，
你已经很好了，
姑娘，
你看你17岁出来自己闯荡，
现在28岁，
你能养活自己，
你不欠债，
你把自己的身体照顾的好好的，
把自己身材照顾的好好的，
你就已经很牛了，
你已经很棒了。
我方还有最后一个问题，
就是我自己现在的话，
就名下这两套房，
还有一辆车子，
两父提出过，
我这个房子按理来说是应该要有一部分分给他的，
这是你自己挣来的，
怎么可能分给他呢？
他提出这样的要求的时候就可以拉黑了啊。
我有一个更决绝的做法，
就是拉黑了之后，
等他们去告你，
如果他们告你，
要你出赡养费的话，
法院判多少给多少，
如果我可以留个什么万一的话，
我怎么样才能避免提前立好公证的遗嘱？
比如你要觉得哥哥的孩子是哥哥在这个世界上的延续，
而哥哥又给了你这个世界上唯一的温。
啊，
你完全可以提前立下公证遗嘱，
我要是真有什么事儿的话，
谁来继承这个财产，
你甚至可以提前立下公证遗嘱，
我要去世了，
这个财产哪怕我捐给居委会，
我捐给那个社会组织都可以，
可以排除你养父母的继承资格的，
你要如果说立这样的遗嘱的话，
第一找公证处，
第二的话，
我觉得还是需要你身边有一些值得信任的人，
谁到时候说我要真出现什么意外了，
别人不认我立的这个遗嘱是吧？
又没有遗嘱，
又不在别人的身上，
等我的养父母来收拾这些东西的时候，
又把这个遗嘱给撕掉了，
毁掉了，
肯定不能允许这样的事儿发生。
我信得过的靠得住的闺蜜朋友可能想说最后一个问题，
我看到有，
呃网友说这个养父母是怎么知道我有房子的，
是因为我的其中的第一套房子是按揭的，
当时按揭的时候是需要这个户口，
就是回家去跟她要这个户口本，
然后他不仅有你想我要这的户口要用做什么，
还知道有这个事情，
好好希望你堡护好自己啊，
咱们女孩子一个人住的话，
装监控，
门口就大个写着有监控一定要堡好自己啊，
好，
拜拜，
你才28岁，
将来你还有自己的孩子，
那你要更要堡护好孩子，
你的财产将来也是自己的孩子的啊，
女孩子啊，
你经济条件好了挣钱。
多买房了买车了，
你都给我咽肚子，
不要炫耀，
也不要告诉任何人，
不要发朋友圈，
因为我今天刷了一个视频，
讲的是什么呢？
妈妈打电话来质问女儿，
你为什么要买房子？
你为什么要买车？
日子过得那么差，
家里条件那么困难，
你怎么那么自私？
真事儿，
我不骗你们，
我今天在网上刷到的，
你们有没有遇到过的遇到过的扣1好像你买房，
你靠你自己的本事攒了钱买房子，
在他看来都是背叛，
都是罪过。
所以女孩子啊，
有钱了，
给我悄悄的变美，
给我悄悄的变健康，
有钱了，
给我悄悄的去认识认识那些跟你在同一个维度的同频的朋友。
少发朋友圈，
记得点赞关注哦。